oh where did you meet your girlfriend uh
oh God that one was uh
no the mile highs I was going to
Antarctica oh hey yo you don't want a
mom do you know what the mile high club
is uh no yeah when you uh fornicate on
an airplane oh my God
transition not the club okay no I was we
were going to Antarctica so we're in
South Africa about to go to Antarctica
Logan I got Casey neistat got the
Entourage we're doing it they're your
entourage and then yeah and then we wake
up and they're just like everyone in
Antarctica has coveted and I'm just like
what does that mean they're like every
single person in the base in Antarctica
tested positive for kova today because
it's like this thing where they let like
billionaires come in and blah blah yeah
and so the billionaire before us was
just like [ __ ] everyone we're just gonna
walk over it and so they're like all in
Antarctic they had to all be medevaced
out and all of it and so like we were
like about to board the plane fly there
and do 50 yards in Antarctica and now
it's just a wasteland there's no one
there to like like clear off the ice
Runway or anything and so we're like you
know maybe we can figure it out so we're
like chilling in South Africa for a
couple of days and then
um I just had dinner with a friend and
then her friend who's my current
girlfriend just stopped by I was like
she just stopped by to say hi to her and
like within five seconds I was like holy
[ __ ] that's this this girl is beautiful
and then but I have to go through the
test because like I don't I don't really
get along with women if like they don't
love learning they're not obsessive they
don't have a hobby they don't like like
there's just certain things where if you
have these traits we get along really
well yeah and if you don't like it's
impossible for us to hang out yeah um so
I had to put her through the ringer and
start asking questions yeah what do you
do and then she was like I'm an author
and I was like [ __ ] yeah good she has a
hobby and then we started talking and I
just tried to get a feel of she likes
learning like you know whatever what do
you like to do you know sounds cringe
but you know like what kind of content
you consume and it was more like
documentary educational yeah and like
the type of stuff she does and she has
multiple degrees you could tell she
likes learning she's about to get a
neuroscience degree just for fun not
even get a job that's amazing because
like she invested in Bitcoin and did
well so she doesn't even like need it
and ever she was like checking all the
boxes I had like these 10 things where
like if I meet a girl that's like
beautiful and they have these 10 traits
like we're gonna be literally best
friends right check every single one of
those feet nice feet uh no that was 11.
okay I could give on that one
my nerdiness is showing because it's
like now I'm here yeah that's where I
come in
the true definition of a nerd like I
just need a partner who loves learning
you know and just wants to improve like
for us now like an idea of a date is
just to like take an IQ test and then
study and see if we can get it higher
like this I love it and I love watching
documentaries I'm like we'll go buy two
books we'll read it and like quiz each
other absolute nerd I'm a [ __ ] nerd
but that's what I needed someone like
that yeah and it's like very hard to
find someone like that that's also like
obviously very beautiful yeah yeah yeah
um and so yeah the second she like
checked all those boxes this is probably
like the like 40th different girl I had
talked to since my ex and I was just
waiting till I found someone that like
moved out all these criteria the second
she checked him I was like that's it
come on yeah wow so then I waited a
couple of days and then I just dm'd her
I was like oh so your book can I read it
she sent it over read the whole book and
it was just like acting like it was the
greatest book ever asking her questions
until we hung out again
yeah and then you officially ask her you
go do you want to be my girlfriend are
you guys just talking well that's where
it's weird because she's in South Africa
yeah which is like a 30 hour flight away
she can't come to America because she
doesn't have a Visa yeah so like this is
how you know I'm Mentor because I'm like
a 30 hour flight there a 30-hour flight
back to go hang yeah so I just fly out
there to hang out there and show that
like I'm a real human because I
literally saw it for like 20 20 30
minutes at dinner yeah and then I
instantly flew back because the
Antarctica shoots canceled yeah and so
it's like it was a little weird at first
because it's not like oh let's just hang
out it's like hey can I spend 30 hours
on a plane to see you yeah and then I
instantly have to spend 30 hours the
next day to fly back because I have a
company to run to yeah and just flying
there takes three entire days to play
[ __ ] so then like the Visa Pro oh this
is where it gets interesting uh to get a
Visa they're like oh take two years like
even like a tourist visa yeah same with
India to hear yeah it's brutal yeah but
one thing that's interesting is if you
when people can't so it's a website you
see all the dates it'll be like the
first dates eight months down the road
well when people cancel it's first come
first serve and so when we found that
out so like we'll we had our appointment
like eight or nine months out but when
someone cancels six months out we just
paid someone to sit there and refresh
and then book it for when it came out
wow so like someone would cancel six
months out yes ours [ __ ] ours now
it's like so it's like great all right
now I get her in six months yeah [ __ ]
perfect [ __ ] flying over there yeah like
two days ago like we just yeah we just
hired this uh person to do it that's all
they did like really all day just
refresh that page and then we get it
four months out I'm like [ __ ] kids it's
great three months every day I'm waking
up and it's getting a little shorter and
then it's like a drought like no
cancellations no nothing I'm like God
damn it I still gotta wait three months
that means I gotta fly to South Africa
like four times to hire her and sponsor
a Visa copywriter I don't know all that
[ __ ] takes time
um but this is the tickets it seems like
a great solution
foreign
[Laughter]
those were options they just take longer
yeah yeah um
[Music]
[Laughter]
which I did think about that at one
point I was like if I just like just
didn't respond to her text like what's
she gonna do it's over she can't fly it
over America yeah so um but anyways I
wake up one day to like 20 missed calls
and the person's like yeah we got an
appointment like five hours from now but
she needs to go there and she was still
asleep so I'm like calling her family to
like go wake her up and someone
literally canceled like that day and she
got in there and oh she got in yeah she
got in and then we it was like nine
months down to like two weeks because we
just took spots when people canceled it
was great
um and then there you go so now she's on
the way uh yeah but then we used up like
80 of the 90 days to get into the
tourist visa so now we're having to
figure out something else because now
she can't really come because yeah I
we're trying to save some days for
Christmas and I I just can't fly to
South Africa it's so far away
because she can only come here 90 days a
year oh tourist visa but they don't
really that's what I know yeah and so
that's why we're about to push it but
there is a chance like she could come
here and they're just like nah [ __ ] you
go back to Africa you don't want to risk
that you go a few days over they check
the books and they're like oops you
can't come in yeah well the worst part
is you don't know till you land so she
can land go through everything and then
the Border age like no go back to
[ __ ] house yeah but at least she's
flying yeah that's true yeah yeah you
know what yeah do you want to see me or
not like that's what you gotta say
that's what I'm currently
next time oh man that's crazy yeah just
like I said she's a nerd like me so like
yeah it's perfect so you guys do like
Zoom dates and stuff uh we honestly we
play Scrabble on our phones
it's it's dumb I feel it now that I say
it out loud I'm realizing how bad it's
gotten no but this is like when you
describe Game of Thrones as someone
who's never watched it and you're
talking about what you believe is the
coolest show ever yeah you were like
dude it's dragons and like castles and
like and I'm like what the [ __ ] are you
watching bro I hope everyone what it is
someone to just read books with me watch
documentaries and just like learn with
me because then if you're not learning
then it's like I can make 100 Grand an
hour or whatever so it's like how can I
justify spending an hour time with you
yeah if I'm not becoming a better person
that's why it's like I have to be
getting better with my partner yeah or
how the [ __ ] am I gonna invest 20 30 000
I literally know the value of your time
yeah basically like every time you go on
a date with her you were spending an
immense amount
that's why I was so particular because I
would it's hard because I've optimized
my life so much in a way where down to
the numbers I can't just shut it off and
be like oh well this doesn't count I
know the value of that two hour date at
[ __ ] Red Lobster I know it and so if
I'm not getting smarter it's just like
it just literally destroys my entire
psychology yeah and I just like I like
lose my mind I'll have a mental like
[ __ ] breakdown I'll be like this is
not like if I extrapolate this out over
10 years I'm [ __ ] like what am I doing
yeah but now that I have someone that
makes me smarter and we like learn
together it's great I afford to
extrapolate I'm way smarter and it works
how serious does that get like when you
go to take a pee are you like
calculating
right now the problem is like we're not
robots so we can't work all the time so
the way I said that's a problem yeah
it's annoying I wish you could so you
gotta you gotta basically when you're
not working you have to be full
decompression so like you're the working
and going 100 miles an hour or you're
like doing nothing you don't like
Outsource everything you shouldn't cook
you shouldn't touching anything you
shouldn't go shopping you should only do
what you feel like doing so you quickly
recharge and then you can get right back
to it you know what I mean so like there
are certain things that are just
necessary because you have to recharge
um like just having fun and not working
what is a big impression for you
um weirdly enough watching documentaries
reading books that kind of stuff like
that's the kind of stuff I enjoy or
watching anime and things like that yeah
and when you're decompressing you need
to be fully decompressing yeah so then
like there's time between you working is
as short as possible so you can just
keep going what's the best documentary
you've seen
I mean the last one I watched was like
on Alexander the Great because like at
one point he ruled half the world yeah
and the other half was owned by like the
um Persian king at the time and they
bodied him too yeah well and they were
like and he was 23 and they were like
hey let's just split the world 50 50.
you can own half the world I'll give you
all this money and the [ __ ] was
like [ __ ] you I want it all right and
when I heard that story I was like
that's crazy so I just like went balls
deep and like learning about this crazy
ass monkey looked at the moon and wept
for he could not conquer it the greed
yeah agreed it's [ __ ] crazy and he
never lost a major battle just such a
badass yeah in every way
um and so yeah that in Persia right he
died in a tent of a disease it was
whatever when he was like 24. yeah
that's right he died young exactly if he
didn't history would be different
last one take it off
yeah
and crazy thing about Alexander the
Great
um from Macedonia
in Italy no Macedonia is its own country
not even part of Greece anymore so we
imagine the most famous Greek person
isn't even Greek
crazy in that wild I must have skipped
that part I didn't know he was
considered Greek yeah no I just thought
of the Greek Empire
we look at that as what what year is
Alexander the Great this is like early
Antigone you know yeah I think so I love
you know your history I like that I like
it a little bit yeah I just think it's
so fascinated like the way that we learn
the world is not reflective of how it is
now yeah so it's been carved up since
yeah it's done by the the winner and
whoever yeah wants to tell the story
yeah like Napoleon to us is this french
guy [ __ ] Corsica yeah he's an Italian
yeah so when he like takes over Italy
they're like well yeah you're from here
well you know there's like one of the
boys Hitler the German who's also
Austrian originally like yeah yeah like
it just doesn't make any sense as you
reflect back because yeah we keep
carving it up and we also yeah we think
it's done but it's not done at all
Russia could very well just take over
Ukraine and now that's Russia again yeah
the USSR split what in the 80s like the
Matthews might take over South Africa
now that's just its own country yeah
next time in a beast Burger we're
marching the Canadian board
you know how he's like I'm standing in
front of a sea of 20 000 people and I
could get them to do whatever you can be
president storm a little bit
oh if you don't have religion you'd be a
psycho yeah yeah that's a little if if
Christianity bro he'd be leading an army
to Canada like think about that like
that's crazy